questa the dx parleremo di smart city e
partecipazione per la precisione
parleremo di partecipazione in una città
che intende essere smart secondo una
definizione che vedremo più in là e
presenteremo anche un metodo una
proposta di soluzione del problema della
partecipazione che non vuole essere un
metodo risolutivo perché ci rendiamo
conto che il problema è un problema
complesso di lungo periodo problema
culturale
voleva essere un inizio per affrontare
il tema
ecco sono necessarie alcune premesse
prima sulla partecipazione per esempio
voi probabilmente ricordate la canzone
di una vecchia canzone di giorgio gaber
che faceva libertà è partecipazione
questo a significare che la
partecipazione non è un optional ma è un
valore un valore fondante della
democrazia
diciamo che la partecipazione di per sé
sarebbe un termine autoesplicativo un
semplice termine che significa prendere
parte condividere se non fosse che
ultimamente nell'ultimo periodo viene
surrogata da un altro termine che è il
consenso
il quale consenso viene calcolato
tramite dei sondaggi cioè delle
operazioni fate su campioni di
popolazione più o meno qualche centinaio
di persone si estrapola il risultato
attraverso un algoritmo e si ottiene
quello che viene definito il consenso e
sulla base di questo si prendono
decisioni più o meno importanti più o
meno strategiche
ed è evidente che stiamo parlando di
tutt'altra cosa
tant'è che gli esiti ed i risultati sono
sono sono evidenti cioè noi stiamo
vivendo in questa fase un periodo di
grave crisi delle rappresentanze un
periodo di grave crisi della
partecipazione la partecipazione in
effetti è un processo a due vie
un processo che coinvolge sia senza
voler confondere il termine con
l'assemblea di smo è un processo a due
vie che coinvolge sia il rappresentante
che il rappresentato li coinvolge nelle
decisioni li coinvolge nelle scelte li
coinvolge nelle proposte questo non sta
avvenendo
ultimamente i risultati sono per esempio
che nelle elezioni che abbiamo ogni
cinque anni nei paesi occidentali sono
ci partecipa la metà della popolazione e
addirittura negli stati uniti meno della
metà
quindi è un problema molto delicato che
occorre affrontare
occorre affrontare in maniera
determinata e a questo proposito noi
oggi possiamo vantare degli strumenti
che ci possono aiutare notevolmente
mi riferisco in particolare agli
strumenti dell'information communication
technology che è una materia che negli
ultimi tempi ha subito dei cambiamenti e
dei miglioramenti tali da diventare
un'altra cosa rispetto a quella che solo
pochi anni fa era una materia per
specialisti o per tecnici oggi è
distribuita
dappertutto ciascuno di noi possiede un
computer o uno smartphone è semplice ad
essere utilizzata giusto per farvi un
esempio 30 anni fa io ero emigrato in
sudafrica per motivi di lavoro
una volta alla settimana aveva la
possibilità di comunicare con la mia
famiglia che stava qui a cagliari e per
fare questo mi dovevo portare
nell'ufficio postale prenotare una
telefonata venivo chiamato dopo una
serie di persone che c'erano prima di me
e questa telefonata avveniva in pochi
secondi pagando fior di quattrini 30
anni dopo mi trovo nella stessa
situazione perché ho un figlio che si
trova in sudafrica per motivi di lavoro
è quotidianamente quando voglio sentito
da casa mia e lui seduto nella casa sua
noi ci sentiamo e ci vediamo questo per
dimostrarvi la crescita incredibile che
hanno avuto questi strumenti di tipo
informatico nel campo della
comunicazione e che oggi noi possiamo
utilizzare per poter affrontare problemi
determinanti come quello che è appunto
il problema dalla partecipazione in
questa democrazia che oggi stanno stanno
sono in crisi appunto perché c'è un
difetto di partecipazione noi il
problema lo esamineremo concentrandoci
sulle città il motivo per cui ci
concentreremo sulle città e perché le
città nelle città vive circa il 50 per
cento della popolazione mondiale è
giusto per darvi quello che è il trend
dello sviluppo nel 1900 nelle città
viveva circa il 13 per cento della
popolazione e nel 2050 le previsioni
dicono che oltre il 70 per cento della
popolazione di vela nelle città
questo per dirvi
per darvi indicazioni di quello che il
trend di sviluppo delle popolazioni
nelle città se in più
consideriamo che oltre il 50 per cento
del pil mondiale viene prodotto nelle
città e che gran parte di questo
prodotto interno lordo mondiale è fatto
di servizi per la città è un luogo
deputato dei servizi quindi la città in
particolare la città smart questo
concetto nuovo di smart city che è una
visione moderna della città innovativa
che avaria definizione sono le
definizioni che noi troviamo nella
letteratura della smart city sono
tantissime sono tantissime
però se l'è esaminiamo tutte tutte hanno
in comune almeno tre cose fondamentali
sono si fondano su tre pilastri reggono
su tre pilastri fondamentali 1 el
innovazione ed in particolare
l'information technology
la seconda è la sostenibilità cioè le
scelte all'interno di queste città che
vogliono essere smart devono essere da
un punto di vista ambientale sostenibili
quindi eco sostenibili terza e la
partecipazione
ecco che quindi noi affronteremo il
problema in questo in questo quadro
quindi possiamo incominciare a pensare
alla proposta preme
forse l'ho detto anche all'inizio che la
proposta non ha l'ambizione di essere
risolutiva perché appunto ci rendiamo
conto che il problema è un problema di
lunga data di lungo respiro ed è
complesso però da pur da qualche cosa
bisogna iniziare
allora la proposta prevede tre step tre
capisaldi fondamentali il primo riguarda
la costituzione di un assessorato alla
partecipazione dell'amministrazione
della smart city come esiste un
assessorato al bilancio perché si
ritiene che il bilancio sia una cosa
importante così come esiste un
assessorato col personale perché il
personale si ritiene sia una cosa
importante
se si ritiene che sia importante la
partecipazione in una smart city
bisogna creare un assessorato alla
partecipazione si potrebbe pensare anche
ad una direzione ad un authority però
personalmente penso che sia preferibile
un assessorato perché il problema non è
un problema di tipo tecnico
il problema è un problema di tipo
politico per cui assessorato alla
partecipazione immagino l'obiezione che
viene ovviamente la prima obiezione che
viene è che la partecipazione è una
questione cross cioè distribuita su
tutti gli assessorati
quindi sarebbe logico che ciascuno si
occupasse della propria effettivamente è
un'obiezione corretta però finora non è
successo finora non è successo
e tra l'altro se consideriamo il
personale anche il personale cross su
tutti gli assessorati
eppure ce lo stesso dato la
partecipazione quindi occorre
un'attenzione specifica a mio avviso su
questo problema per poterlo affrontare
il secondo step secondo caposaldo è
quello della istituzione di un
regolamento per l'amministrazione
condivisa
cioè di un regolamento che disciplini la
condivisione dell'amministrazione cioè
che disciplini i ruoli dei cittadini e
degli amministratori attribuendo a
ciascuno le proprie responsabilità i
propri diritti ed i propri ruoli
non c'è bisogno di inventare l'acqua
calda perché un regolamento di questo
tipo
esistono vari regolamenti di questo tipi
di questo tipo sono già conosciuti e
utilizzati dai comuni italiani
esistono delle associazioni onlus oppure
no profit che sono a disposizione per
questo scopo
io sto pensando per esempio ad
un'associazione che si chiama labsus che
ha fornito questi questo regolamento a
vari comuni già in in inattività in
italia per cui basta riferirsi a questi
adattarlo alle proprie esigenze e
partire ed ecco quindi il metodo vero e
proprio il terzo step
supponiamo che l'amministrazione abbia
esigenza voglia migliorare l'ambiente
della propria città e a questo proposito
fa una proposta in cui per esempio
propone di ridurre il carico veicolare
privato aumentare quello pubblico di in
particolare di sviluppare
il trasporto di tipo elettrico car
sharing bike sharing e così via giusto
l'esempio soltanto l'esempio è fatto con
una proposta dell'amministrazione ma
potrebbe avvenire anche l'inverso cioè
la proposta può essere iniziata dei
cittadini fatta propria
dall'amministrazione è poi proseguita
nell'iter che descriverò quindi
l'amministrazione fa questa proposta e
la assegna all assessorato alla
partecipazione il quale seguendo un
procedimento operativo ed utilizzando
degli strumenti di comunicazione sia di
tipo tradizionale che di tipo innovativo
che vedremo dopo si rivolge alla
popolazione distinta ai cittadini
distinti in cittadini semplici
associazioni ed imprese perché è giusto
distinguerli perché hanno una visione
dei problemi diversa e quindi è giusto
che vengano fornite queste visioni si
rivolgerlo rappresentando questa
proposta ricevendo delle risposte delle
osservazioni delle negazioni e così via
discorrendo riformulando riadattando la
proposta reiterando il processo
scremando così fino ad arrivare ad una
soluzione finale ad una proposta finale
che sottoporrà referendum il quale
referendum darà origine ad un risultato
e alla fine di questo processo iterativo
prende il pacchetto e lo da
all'amministrazione che è sempre lei in
capo delle decisioni cioè
l'amministrazione sarà sempre lei a
decidere cosa fare e cosa non fare solo
che in questo caso la decisione è frutto
di una scelta partecipativa gli
strumenti di comunicazione che
utilizzerà l'assessorato alla
partecipazione come dicevo sono di due
tipi strumenti di tipo tradizionale e
strumenti di tipo innovativo strumenti
di tipo tradizionale sono quegli
strumenti
lo dice la parola tradizionali e quindi
televisione assemblee
radio volantini e così via discorrendo
il gli strumenti di tipo innovativo
invece si fondano su un portale su un
portale di accesso unico della
comunicazione in sostanza una
piattaforma internet che prevede di
chiamiamole così due pagine una per
l'amministrazione ed una per il per i
cittadini è sia gli uni che gli altri
riempiono queste pagine delle loro
osservazioni delle loro proposte
utilizzando gli strumenti di social
network di cui siamo che abbiamo a
disposizione quindi proviamo a pensare
l'amministrazione che nel momento in cui
fa la proposta manda dei video di tipo
youtube utilizza facebook utilizza
twitter permette delle osservazioni
interviste al sindaco eccetera eccetera
eccetera
la stessa cosa viene nella parte per
quello che riguarda i cittadini con le
loro osservazioni via youtube con le
loro osservazioni su facebook su
facebook le loro proposte le loro
integrazioni eccetera eccetera eccetera
tutto questo è sotto la gestione
dell'assessorato alla partecipazione e
questa è la proposta io immagino che
l'obiezione prima che viene in mente è
che è molto è possibile che una volta
che si mette in mano della cittadinanza
uno strumento così potente come quello
che ho descritto
l'amministrazione la stessa data la
partecipazione venga subissato di una
serie di osservazioni ed idee tali da
poter mettere in difficoltà la gestione
stessa
la mia risposta è che se ci dovessimo
trovare in questa situazione secondo me
metà del percorso è già stato fatto
vi ringrazio